你的作品都有老人味，谁愿意爱你？
往困境的人身上扔石头，大姐都是慷慨的。
当真相还在穿鞋的时候，
这个谎言趁着互联网的话已经跑遍了全世界，无依自白。
每一个人好像都感受到了一种找不着落脚之处的一个焦虑感，对未来的不确定性。
你比如说每天这个牛啊，打工挣钱，上有牢，下有小，
那生活的非常具体，也非常的粗励。
他的乐趣支撑着他没有乐趣的工作，甚至没有乐趣的生活。
老挤辛苦了，压力别太大。
我以为您不喝咖啡，您是喝咖啡的？
都行。
因为我记得咱们上一回四五年前二一年的时候，
您当时是喝茶，
您还总给我倒茶，然后搞得我特别不好意思。
当时你们准备的是茶，
今天准备的是咖啡。
咱们上一次录就是二一年的夏天，
然后现在咱们到了这个二六年的冬天，
也算是二五年的冬天，刚来到这个一月份。
其实我第一个问题最想聊的就是，
这四五年来您觉得您最大的变化是什么？
因为四五年之前，当时出版的是一日三秋。
然后四五年之后呢，出版是显得玩笑。
我觉得对于作者来讲，
输的变化就是最大的变化，
因为它的变化基本上都在输里面。
这是非常重要的。
这本书的话，大家觉得这个变化是对还是不对。
是由然而生的，还是刻意维持。
最后的话，我觉得判断还是在读着嘛。
就是有时候这个创作的过程，
并不是作者写完这本书，
这个创作过程就完成了。
其实仅仅到达了一半。
另外一半的话呢，就是还是读着读着之后，
他把这个创作给完成了。
就是显得玩笑的话呢，就是，
对我最大的这个畏忌，
也不单单是他的，
你现在就在一个月多一点嘛，
一个多月的话呢，
但是他的发酵量，
这个当时发酵量目前的话，
你到六十万册也算是好的吧。
哦，已经六十万册了，那非常高啊。
我自己看这个书的时候看的很快，
但当时呢，正好是晚上，
你一上来写这个杜太白，
对饺子的展望把我给写饿了，
对，然后你看他要吃一个饺子，
他会有这么多的展望，
然后突然就让我理解了，
您上那个向往的生活里面，
您会问对这个菜花有什么展望，
然后我就明白了展望这两个字是什么意思，
然后我就想问就是，
您自己在平时的生活里面，
对于一日三餐会有这么细节的展望吗？
一日三餐的话呢，
就是在生活中是非常日常，
而且呢，非常瑣碎，
但是到了温学的层面的话，
恰恰的话呢，
有时候瑣碎之中的乐趣，
在生活中被忽略着瑣碎的乐趣，
恰恰的话呢，
有时候是温学特别重视的，
看似写的，
不是讲是今天晚上吃什么，
像杜太白，
今天中午吃什么，
今天早着吃什么，
这一日三餐，
看似写的是一日三餐，
其实他跟人物结合起来，
就像杜太白，
他会对所有的这些，
吃什么，
怎么吃，
怎么吃和之间呢，
形成一个结构，
早餐，午餐和晚餐，
那这一个的话，
它有一种思考，
乐趣并不产生在食物，
乐趣产生在对这些食物结构安排的，
这样一种思考，
这个思考，
有时候就特别的，
是为日常生活忽略着那种乐趣，
而且对这个人物的，
他在面貌，
他在性格，
包括的话呢就是，
这个典型的人物形象，
他会起一个特别坚实的一个，
跟打地剑一样的一个作用，
别讲开头的话呢，
就是好像是从拉班歇起，
就是这个杜太白就说，
清早吃什么，
杜太白呢，
他是一个现成的知识分子，
他的世界观，人生观，
包括方法论，
因为他自己独特的一些特点，
他连既然你要弄那个拉班州，
那确实对一个拉班州的样子，
什么叫样子呢？
就是说呢，
把拉班州里边这些杂班的，
所有的原材料，
你再跟他凑齐啊，
你不凑齐他怎么叫拉班州呢？
这个是杜太白跟别人的区别，
他还是个很认真，
包括很想认真生活，
包括旅亲每一个生活细节的一个一个人，
所以的话呢，
就是他想凑齐了这个料，
这个料是什么呀？
大米小米，
一米一米，
红枣,
桂圆,
莲子,
花生,
红豆,
绿豆,
黄豆,
黑豆,
云豆,
一向不能老想，
出个周全，
这是他的思考，
但是最后的话呢，
还是凑不齐，
凑不齐怎么办呢？
他突然又思考了一下，
他任何事，
一开始都想凑齐，
但凑不齐，
有自我安慰，
万事古难全，
没有也就算了，
这是他这个，
对拉班州思考的过程，
这个过程的话呢，
可能大家走了之后，
就这也有意思，
但这个思考过程，
其实在日常生活中的话呢，
就是,
所有人都会想，
在街道的话呢，说好，
这个清早吃拉班州，
中午吃什么，
那拉班肯定中午在吃饺子，
说爱吃什么馅子呢？
他又在想，
一个是猪肉混香馅子，
一个是猪肉芹菜馅，
这俩都爱吃，
那怎么办呢？
因为他一个人生活嘛，
然后跟这个妻子离婚了，
然后的话呢，
就是正在谈恋爱，
跟那个最像一个闹辩用了，
是吧?
所以这种自己吃饭，
所以一人吃饭是非常难弄的，
你知道饭馆点菜，
一人也最怕一人点菜，
不能毫无不断，
又开始思考了，
那就两种都包点，
而且煮的时候也有思考，
所以一块煮出来的话呢，
就是吃住谁算谁，
就是吃住混香的，
就是混香的，
吃住芹菜的就是芹菜的，
然后的话呢，
接着就，
那就去买点原材料，
到菜市场买点芹菜，
买点混香，
肉不能买到太多，
因为肉在馅里看的太多，
就腻了，
而且呢，
为什么就是，
吃过喇叭都在去买呢？
那是因为的话，
你不能买得太早，
买得太早的，
你把菜买过来就一人了，
你昨天买的肉，
我今天在弄的话，
就反兴了，
现买现包，
是吧?
是个生活，
很仔细，
很讲究的人嘛，
买多少呢？
四两个都足够了，
一个人吃饺子，
三十个足够了，
那十五个里边，
二两肉也就够了，
你不然用力了，
所以就出门，
出门的话呢，
去买这个，
混香,
买这个芹菜，
又买点肉，
混香,
芹菜都买了，
出了菜市场，
突然发现了就是，
有一个羊肉铺，
新鲜的羊，
这个肉呢，
猪肉的话呢，
到前面那个猪肉铺呢，
它是动肉，
突然想起来，
我爱吃羊肉，
接着就问这个，
肉哪来的呀？
内嘛,
胡伦贝尔草原，
羊是赶过来的，
今天早上的话呢，
这个羊的话呢，
刚刚的话呢，
就到另外一个世界，
说着有新鲜的肉，
为什么我要买动肉呢？
羊肉和大肉比起来，
我更愿意吃羊肉，
但是羊肉不能配混香和芹菜，
但这两卖了怎么办？
是吧?
它又是个问题，
就也开始思考这个问题，
最后想了想，
吃到3000匹有路，
遇到再多的困难，
还是要把它解决，
这是关于这个混香和，
群菜的思考的话，
道理非常大，
前下没有职业人之路，
这混香啊，
我拿回家呀，
我再抽一下，
拌成凉刺，
拉八周不是没吃完吗？
没有早就在吃的时候，
当一小咸刺，
芹菜怎么办呢？
我也抽一下，
也拌成凉刺，
既然拌芹菜，
芹菜最好的伙伴是什么呢？
花生米，
我停车就买这花生米，
也不买多，
一两花生米，
二两芹菜，
一半这喝酒，
当个下酒刺，
就是混香的话是喝拉八周的，
这个是喝酒的，
这个按制了，
但是还有俩问题，
你问题的话呢，
你要是羊肉的话呢，
你再配胡萝卜最好，
但刚才在菜上忘了买这个胡萝卜，
这怎么办啊？
不买胡萝卜，
也没有天大的事让我处理，
再去买胡萝卜，
再去一趟，
接着还有一问题，
不好弄，
原来是说啊，
这个中午吃饺子，
晚上呢，
一点点就不做饭了，
准备的话呢，
去喝个羊汤，
然后那个羊杂碎，
再喝几两酒，
那种中午吃羊肉的饺子，
那晚上这个羊肉，
它醇了就怎么办，
说,
中午改，
晚上也在跟着改，
那要不就改，
自己跟自己商量，
改成啥呢？
想着想去，
说有一家就是那个，
做飘香鱼子挺好啊，
鱼汤顿子也有滋味儿，
这不晚上吃鱼不就完了吗？
你看,
想通了，
就拍板了，
就是在这个世界上，
肚腩白的话呢，
肚胀的话改变了，
看似是吃饭的方向，
其实是世界幽转的方向，
就这种转转反侧和多度转转的看似的话呢，
是,
这个肚腩白，
一日三餐吃什么，
其实写的不单是吃什么，
它是,
肚腩白的就是世界观，人生观，
包括的话呢就是，
它整个的这个思维系统，
它是一个什么样的人，
这个,
最忌讳的，
就对做者来讲呢，
你直接用理性的语言，
来描述肚腩白是个什么样的人，
那这个是你的创作，
读着话嘛，
也能看明白，
但是通过这个一日三餐的话呢，
就是它的，
世界观、方法论和思维习惯呢，
这是读着读出来的，
它是通过细节，
那是读着的话，
它自己是会有创造的，
有好多人的话，
还是很喜欢读太白的，
这个人挺有意思，
你看任何事的话，
它都是，
它的思维习惯跟别人不是特别一样，
可能这个不一样的话，
对大家阅读，
它可能还是有好处的，
这是第一点，
我觉得更重要的一点的话呢，
就是,
小时候还必须要讲究生动性，
那生动，
听哪里来，
对小时候来讲的话呢，
有几个基本的因素，
一个的话呢就是，
语言对话，
别让他跟老马的这个对话，
他跟自己的对话，
还有一个是细节，
还有一个的话呢就是，
听点,
还有一个是故事，
还有的是这个人，
因为,
我是说过，
文学的底色是哲学，
但是文学可不能写成哲学，
因为哲学是要，
用理性的道理把这个世界，
把这个人给说明白嘛，
但这个对文学没用，
文学恰恰是要，
文学的哲学是要说那些，
用哲学说不清楚的那个领域，
不是讲你让那个康德，
说你就把那个独太白，
一日三餐，
你给分析清楚，
那他肯定是另外一个话语系统，
这个话语系统它是一个道理和，
理性的系统，
但是文学的理性恰恰是埋的最深的，
埋的最深也是一个哲学，
就是,
他们最本质的区别的话呢就是，
哲学的话确实是思考，
这个世界的，
比如讲像社会的层面，
包括的话呢就是，
政治的层面，
社会运行的规律，
政治运行的规律，
人类运行的规律，
没有问题，
哈尔也是这么描述的，
但是文学的话恰恰是要说那些，
没有规律的东西，
这是另一个哲学，
就回到吃这件事情上，
我在想就是，
杜太白他对吃这么认真，
也反映出来他对生活的一种，
态度是一个有生机的状态，
因为后来他不是遇上事了吗，
你看他对吃也不上心了，
然后等到他这个又峰回路转的时候，
又开餐馆了，又开始上心了，
我记得你看你这个最后一张，
这个知味社嘛对吧，
上面的那个牌匾是，
人间烟火器，
卫辅烦人心，
横批室，
就是好吃对吧，
我就在想，
您这里边是不是也有一种态度，
就是说，
老百姓对于这个吃的上心，
就能把这个日子过得热闹，
然后当一切有变故，
各种外界的东西来了以后，
吃是我们守卫这个东西的一个底线。
这个冰心的思考的话呢，
也是一种思考，
这种思考的话呢，
就是也是对的，
起码有一个方向它是对的，
那杜太白，
当他到了困境的时候，
他就是没有心思，
来讲就吃的了，是吧，
这个,
没心思讲就吃的是因为他有心事，
心事闹的他没有心思，
包括就是，
你看咱们前面说，
他的这个饺子的展望花了这么长的时间，
包括你看他到这个饭馆里这么讲就，
其实我也读到了一种这个，
从从融融游刃有余的感觉，
您知道这个梗是吧，
对对对，
然后这个时候我又想到了您的表哥牛顿，
对,
他也是给我一种从从融融游刃有余的感觉，
你就比如说他不是个尼瓦将吗，
你以前说过他这个，
在镇上接了活，
别人是带这个干粮，
他是不带的，
他有展望对吧，
然后,
所以我就在想就是，
您说他有展望的时候，
您回头又给他有个对话，
您说这个，
哥你平常挺辛苦的，
你辛苦了，
然后,
您表哥说，
我弟,
你更辛苦，
因为你心里藏的事比我多，
而我觉得，
您说到这儿的时候，
我觉得他有感触了，
就是,
像,
贵为刘正宇老师对吧，
其实快乐是很难的，
纠正一层，
免贵性流，
对对对，
就是,
快乐是很难的，
别说您的快乐难了，
其实,
就哪怕是我们在做的，
快乐都已经很难，
远不如像这个牛顿表哥一样，
他对食物有个展望，
他就挺快乐的，
你就比如说，
我今天要采访您吧，
我前天晚上就已经睡不着了，
我就开始倒层我这个提缸，
对吧,
我就想，
这个刘老师聊不了，
那个要不要聊，
为什么呢？
就是因为，
您看,
您这么厉害，
这个口才这么好，
我还老担心，
万一我们被别人给比下去怎么办？
对吧?
包括说，
因为咱们四五年前聊过一回，
咱们这个采访在网上的，
这个不放量特别高，
我又想，
那这次，
不能比上回低啊，
是吧?
这个就是，
想要的东西太多，
你这个快乐就难了，
其实您也是一样的，
是不是？
我从一个月前，
就开始睡不着了，
另外的话，
大家爱看不爱看的话呢，
我觉得，
更重要的是，
是不是不同了？
因为今天我们聊着这话题的话呢，
就是,
我没跟别人聊过，
因为别人也没这么误过，
但是四五年前，
咱俩的话呢，
就是聊天，
也没这么聊过，
我觉得，
这个是非常非常重要的，
这是一方面，
另外一方面，
你别要说到像我，
比较哥，
我觉得他也是个不同的人，
对,
然后的话呢，
就是在，
正常打工一百块钱，
是吧?
他一定要拿出二十块钱，
我到这个镇上吃饭，
是吧?
嗯,
有点像杜太太，
对,
嗯,
杜太太小时候，
不也叫牛顿吗？
对,
嗯,
就是,
我今天的话呢，
就是吃这个，
胡辣汤，
嗯,
容易火烧，
牛顿的话呢，
就是我一定要改一样，
然后就是，
羊肉会面，
后天的话，
其实我可以吃个，
炒饼,
嗯,
这大后天的话，
再吃个茄子饶面，
然后这个，
那大大后天呢，
这叫做，
嗯,
每次都不同，
对,
他这样的话，
你看说是一个农民，
他对生活的安排，
其实是有考虑的，
嗯,
有考虑的人，
都是有思想的人，
嗯,
这个,
有一次我回这个老家，
嗯,
他给我就是拿了一个，
这是在地里边，
然后用手机拍子，
嗯,
这是,
在地里干了一阵活儿，
嗯,
就是一个农民坐在，
装着地在，
地头上，
在干嘛，
是危机分吗？
当然了，
而且的话，
你看一看这个，
提的话有多么的复杂，
那你这个的话，
可能你在生活中，
你觉得他就是个农民，
但是,
这个,
极义农民，
其实每个农民，
可以,
每个农民都是不一样的，
而且,
还有这样的牛顿的农民，
这也是我对生活，
包括对温学，
包括的话，
有时候对思考，
另外一个，
特别广阔和坚实的基础，
生活中，
有那么多的话呢，
就是,
值得你尊重，
值得你信赖，
值得你的话呢，
就是,
把这个，
一个农民，
这一面，
不为人知的东西，
给展示出来，
我觉得这是我写作的一个，
特别重要的一个动力，
复杂性对于温学是非常非常重要的，
你这个写的人物特别的，
就是,
在意,
扁平,
那这个的话呢，
不是,
不是温学的范畴，
包括说，
您说这个，
像表哥一样，
在田间地头，
他会拿出来这个，
危机分开始在这儿算，
然后您其实，
最近也提了一个词，
就是叫，
异彩嘛，
对吧,
您小说里面，
其实也写了很多这样，
有异彩的人物，
对吧,
然后我就在琢磨，
您说的这个异彩，
是不是跟我们平常说，
就是我们每个人的，
那个生活的支点，
是一个东西，
想跟您探讨探讨，
我叫这，
冰写说的特别好，
但是人生的支点，
这个人看似是这样，
其实他也有另一面，
他好多面，
是他好多面，
只称了这一个面，
特别是对于，
人生是这样，
人性更是这样，
人性的话呢，
不为人知的那一面，
什么叫不为人知呢？
就是不为别人知道，
这是不为人知，
他其实更重要的是，
连自己有时候都忽略了，
不知道，
他是人性的另一面，
这人性的另一面的话，
恰恰是不为人知，
支撑着为人知，
背后支撑着表面，
这个是，
也是一个哲学，
但这个哲学的话，
在每一个人身上，
都是一样的，
你说这个，
我的表哥，
支撑着，
干装这活儿，
包括到工地去打工的，
到底是什么？
他自己可能有时候，
也没有意识到，
但是的话呢，
他确实就是对，
这个,
高灯数学，
高灯物理，
一个农民，
那么的痴迷，
那种痴迷就，
支撑着他的日常生活，
而且他这不是有意的，
他说,
这就是他的乐趣，
乐趣,
他的乐趣，
支撑着他，
有时候，
没有乐趣的工作，
甚至没有乐趣的生活，
但一个人，
他总有一个有乐趣的，
这种背后的，
这种支撑，
那这个乐趣的支撑是什么？
也是闲得玩笑，
探头的，
另外一个特别重要的一个问题，
您刚刚说，
这个,
异彩这个事儿，
我不是问您说，
我说这四五年，
有什么变化吗？
其实我的感受就是，
其实咱们身边的每一个人，
好像都感受到了一种，
就是,
对未来的不确定性，
然后对于自己，
就是找不着落脚之处的一个焦虑感，
然后我就发现，
现在的网上，
不管是年轻人，
还是网络上更多的人，
他们就都开始，
找这个自己的异彩了，
你比如说，
我在网上看到有的人，
他可能平常生活中，
他是咱们普通的小白领，
对吧,
但是他回去以后，
他自己会做这个博物馆的文创，
他自己做，
就是他嫌那个博物馆自己出的那个，
就是那个冰洋贴，
不立体，
他自己把那个几个面都打出来，
包括说就是，
他们到了周末，
他这个，
这个办公室里面，
看着很普通的小白领们，
就是我们所有人，
对吧,
他可能到了周末，
他就是另外一个人，
像您说的那个词叫，
闭面,
我觉得这就好像就是，
咱们应对这个，
无处落脚的那个焦虑，
不确定的那个未来的一个抓手，
他就自己在自救的那种感觉，
包括有一个词，
我不知道您听没听过，
叫爱你老挤，
对,
您这个书里写这个的时候，
就知道我想起来那个，
爱你老挤最常见的一个帖子，
就是说，
我想喝奶茶，
老挤说，
现在就下单，
他就有一种，
对吧,
有这个官罩在，
就跟您写的这个，
都太白也好，
小人物的一彩也好，
都很像，
所以我说，
您确实作为文学家，
是有非常非常敏锐的一面的，
就是发现，
咱们想要，
寻求一种具体的解决办法来，
关注自己的这个念头，
说到特别好，
因为这个人的话呢，
就是不是光有A面，
如果一个人固执的，
不就有A面，
这个事的话呢，
就是,
这个性质就是这样的，
他容易得意欲着，
因为他就是，
从A面得出不来，
其实人的话呢，
除了有A面，
还有B面，
还有C面，
还有G面，
还有E和F面，
多面的话，
才组成了一个人嘛，
其实恰恰是，
B面、C面、D面，
E面和F面，
它支撑着这个A面，
因为A面，
它是在街上走的这个人，
是的。
而且的话呢，
就是,
后面这几个面的话呢，
就是像B面、C面、D面、
E面和F面，
有时候并不为人说之，
并不为自己说之，
这个,
你刚才说那个词的话呢，
它就是另外一个B面，
就是我知道有一个词的话，
叫老几，
老几说的是自己，
是吧,
要不要那一场，
老几,
现在就嘛，
它其实成了两个人，
在对话嘛，
这就是A和B这种对话嘛，
然后前不久的话呢，
就是,
也是出版事，
他们出了一个主意，
就是像在那个，
有的那个便利店，
然后弄了个小黑包，
然后说你在上面，
先写个字，
看大家下边跟不跟，
好多城市，
我在上面呢，
就写了就是，
这个梳理的一句话，
街上走的每一个人，
其实大家都辛苦了，
没想到这个在网上也爆了，
是的，是的，
说好多人都在留言，
而且好个留言的话呢，
就是我看了之后，
我就说这出的可不是B面，
又是C面和D面，
而且上面说的，
全是邮中的话，
便利店嘛，
便利店的文学角，
这个有时候的话呢，
就是,
它其实不搭嘎的，
到便利店人家就买个奶茶呀，
有时候买个泡面呀，
有时候买个香肠啊，
人一起来就走了，
但是呢，
在这个，
买表面东西的时候，
它把性命话留在了黑板上，
而且所有人看到，
给我感触也特别适应，
然后那个，
我看了，
就是摘了几个，
妈妈早点下班，
这样镜头，
对对，镜头，
那我来举着吧，
来,来,
您能看看啊，
你看吧，
一个就是，
一个就是上一年级的小女孩，
在上写了一个，
妈妈早点下班，
还有一个呢，
就是你说的就是，
比如说她的白领啊，
她写的是，
白天与风雨过招，
回家时清升河上门，
我觉得特别，
特别感人意识，
还有一个就说些，
老几辛苦了，
老几来了，
压力别太大，
还有一个写的，
我觉得都，
特别大的这些家才能写出来，
泪水之下，
漂浮着我们全部的生活，
她就说，
在这跟闲着玩笑，
然后的话呢，
就是,
比如说这个生活里边，
就是人的这种多面性，
有说是，
非常有意思，
也是非常有意义的，
而且是多面性，
她支撑着，
每一个人，
这么多人呢，
她支撑着这个生活了，
是,
有说生活的，
就是像这个杜太白一开始，
就是我跟冰心聊的，
就是这个一日三餐的安排，
就生活的趣味性有说是非常非常重要的，
是的，是的，
有说你恰恰发现的话呢，
就是,
你能靠趣味性活着吗？
还不在靠这个，
你比如说每天这个牛啊，
打工挣钱，
上有老，下有小，
是，是的，
那生活的非常具体，
也非常的粗励，
也非常的严厉，
你必须要支撑下来，
但你其实有时候这个底色的话，
有说恰恰是生活的趣味性，
有时候人的话呢，
都为什么需要好朋友呢？
是吧,
恰恰的话呢，
有说首先是趣味向头，
或者臭味向头，
是吧,
他们才能在一块，
就是,
有些女孩子在一起就是，
七七啧啧说的是吧，
然后笑得那么开心，
这就是趣味性，
你说的她一定，
一定不是讨论的是世界大事，
就是身边的生活所事嘛，
那就证明生活所事里边，
还是有，
非常大的乐趣在里边，
而这个乐趣的话呢，
有时候可能在生活中被我们忽略了，
我觉得这个也是大家对闲的玩笑，
然后的话能，
给予这种心流的，
这种相互流动的一个，
特别重要的另外一个原因。
我前两天看到那个宋方津老师给您这个书写了一个评论，
我觉得他写的还真挺好，
他说作家刘正云的身份，
一直在发生变化，
他说在这个一地心毛阶段，
他是一个作者，
他自己用自己这个话筒，
那个咱这个话筒，
他书里的人物是他的话筒，
他自己有话要说。
到了我不是潘金莲，
一句点一万句，
他是个亲听者，
听这个角色在说话，
他说但是到了闲的玩笑，
他又变了，
他变了一个影者，
影于咱们说的这个严金宇宙，
然后听看这些人，
然后跟他们一起生活，
然后最后对大家说一声，
大家都辛苦了，
我觉得他这个影者这个概念，
贵娜的真挺好，
因为,
方金的话是个很有雄的人，
他的话就是，
古今中外的书他读得特别特别多，
另外的话就是，
他是个知识分子，
就是,
但是他的模样的话，
长得不像个知识分子，
但是确实是个知识分子，
因为知识分子的话呢，
就是,
他不但是要读书，
而且他会有自己的见识，
他对好多事情的，
这个贵娜提炼总结，
有时候总是很到位，
比如让他说的话呢，
也不但是说我，
就是作家他创造的几个阶段，
那当第一个阶段的话呢，
你为什么要写这本书？
是因为你有话要说，
那当第二个阶段的话呢，
不是你有话要说，
是书里的人，
人间有话要说，
你听得够，
那当然的话，
第三层面的话呢，
让我就是更好了，
我也不知道我是不是做到了，
就是,
大千事业，
行星色色，
云云众生，
那里边的话呢，
就是像这个海水下巴的那种污流和潜流一样，
然后的话呢，
你深入到海底之下，
你没了，
海啸是有它，
然后的话呢，
就是大江综区浪淘进，
如果是大江的话，
它是有它，
就是这些本身的话呢，
我觉得，
对于一个作者是非常非常重要的，
因为这里边还提到另外一个堂堂的是，
就是杜甫，
就是坊间说这个呢，
也符合杜甫的就是它三个阶段，
它第一个阶段的话，
当时二三十岁的时候，
它呢也去过泰山嘛，
惠当林结鼎，
是的，是的，
这个诗的话，
有时候跟李白的诗区别不是特别的美吧，
嗯,
李白也是，
招辞白地，
彩云间，
千里江陵，
李日华，
是吧,
嗯,
但这种豪卖的，
就是对世界有话要说的阶段，
是一个毕竟的阶段，
嗯,
但是到这个，
经历过世事沧桑，
然后这个杜福的话呢，
他就写出了另外一种，
嗯,
不是他的声音，
是他看到的，
世界发出来的声音就是，
嗯,
诸门井肉臭，
路由洞死谷，
这看到的，
这个惠当林结鼎一辆重山小，
他好像是俩世界，
是吧,
嗯,
你在诸门井肉臭，
路由洞死谷的时候，
嗯,
你说不出来就是，
一览重山小，
重山并不小，
重山就是，
这个,
诸门井肉臭，
路由洞死谷，
就是这个客观环境的变化，
有时候也会，
给一个人极大的这种，
冲击,
包括改变，
改变之后的感触，
跟以前又不一样，
因为按时之乱的话，
对杜福的，
冲击非常非常大，
嗯,
他永远没想到就是唐朝，
就是被这个二龙山，
他突然成那个，
那样一种状态，
这个,
杜福都当过俘虏，
嗯,
所以这个时候，
他又说出了就是，
国破山河在，
成春草物生，
那就是这个，
他是个客观的存在，
但这个客观的存在，
跟杜福这个时候的感触，
突然给撞上了，
嗯,
就是,
国破山河在，
成春草物生，
这两句适合，
真是写的特别特别棒，
嗯,
你看,
国家是没了，
是吧,
但山河都还在，
嗯,
这个,
长安城也在，
是吧,
嗯,
但长满了草物，
他也是春天，
嗯,
当然,
他到了晚年的话呢，
就是在四川嘛，
这个,
杜福草堂，
嗯,
成都,
然后,
生活比较淒凉了，
嗯,
毛巫衣，
秋风所迫，
嗯,
然后就是，
安德广沙，
千万间，
大笔,
天下,
永远是无之惊的
生活永不停止
是是是
但是
认识有时候你自己停止了。
那这是你的事
这是包括的话
就是有的
看似
这个很年轻
但是思想很古典
古典是个客气话了。
是
停止不前
那也要说的话
就是像
这个
老子
活了两天多岁了
像豆腐里白
白鸡翼
就活了一千多岁了。
曹雪芹的话也活了快300岁了。
你再拿起他们的书。
看看
依然
年轻和感兴
那我觉得他们
他们的青春气味生会这么长。
那我觉得
他对这个世界
那种
这个
透彻和痛彻的思考。
是分不开的
这个
你想李白的话
就是像这样的诗
就是
金人不见古时月
金月曾经照顾人
那这么诗的话
这不是一般诗
说能写出来的
而且在这本书里边。
我也给那个
像谁致敬了
像孩子
他虽然活了20多岁。
但是他的诗
我觉得将来也会
穿越千年
今天夜里
我不关心全人类
这种诗我觉得真是。
达到了像李白豆腐。
这样的景界
身边
每个人的身边
还是有人的
还是有好多就是
值得自己学习的这样的。
深思考
而且的话
又写出了那么多
好的文章的这些人。
生活
不停
思考不停
这是
什么是好书
这个
只读一遍的书就放下来的书。
不是好书
或者是读了几页放下来。
更不说了
这本书你经常看
每次看的话都好像。
哎
还是有心意的
就是
那这样
这本书里它含的这种。
展新的思想
它会穿越
时间和空间
这个有时候
可能是一个坐着
想追求的一个
方向
我未必做到了
但是的话
我知道往哪个方面去努力吧？
对
包括说您刚刚也提到了。
写作的心态问题
其实也是我想跟您探讨的一个话题。
我刚才看了那个波夫瓦的一本书叫老年。
他就有个观点
他就说老年作家
您不老 但是只不过跟以前的那个您比。
肯定是比以前老一些的。
就是他就说老年作家。
其实小说是最难写的。
他可以写随笔记
可以写回忆录
但因为小说
他需要有强烈的想象力。
创造力以及跟现实之间的这种互动。
您刚刚其实也提到这个。
他的意思就是说
一切决策理所应当的人。
他是写不了小说的。
对
所以我觉得您刚刚其实也在回应这个话题。
就是如果说咱们这个年龄。
可能确实老了一点。
那怎么能够继续写作。
那就是要保持跟世界之间的这种活跃的关系。
但是波夫瓦这个话的话。
说的是对
但世界上不存在
绝对的对
是的
波夫瓦的观点的话。
可能是相对比较困难的。
对很容易自我重复。
因为
这个小说的
故事结构和人物结构。
他有时候这种广阔度和深入度。
有可能的话
就是像随笔和三文。
随笔和三文一段情绪就可以写。
没有问题
到个时刻
但这是一方面
但是的话
是真正的和亲的话。
就是并不是的话
就是这个题材的难度。
而是这个写作者的难度。
写作者的难度的话。
就是跟他写作的时间和年龄。
其实是没有太大的关系。
有太大的关系
也没有太大的关系。
我觉得那当然的话。
就是可以有
另外一个角度
这个角度的话
是这个人的话
这个人的话
他心不心
如果这个人很心的话。
他心在哪
我觉得不是他穿的衣服。
也不是他留的髮型。
最重要的
就是他有没有心的思想。
如果他有心的思想的话。
这个心的思想
会自然会写出另外一个。
新的作品
这是一方面
另外一方面的话
一个人为空间和时间所困。
就是困在时间里的人。
和困在空间里的人。
这个也是很麻烦的。
但是刚才我们举的例子。
像老子
像孔子
像李白祖父
白居逸
像苏东多
包括像李清照
包括一直到曹杰清。
你现在读他们的
读他们的文章
读他们的诗
读他们的词
现在的话很年轻的。
能写出来吗？
我就说未必
要能写出来早写出来了。
是吧？
如果现在的话又出现了几个。
孔子老子
叫司马谦
李白祖父
白居逸
李清照
像苏氏
曹杰清
那不更好吗？
他为什么没出现
那你说
年龄比的话是这些人。
年轻的
还是那些人年轻
肯定是那些人年轻。
有些人已经死了
但他得活着
您说的
咱们说的这些什么曹杰清。
他们很年轻
时空的大概念里面。
我刚刚给您聊的
刘仁云老师为例
您自己的一个时间夸度。
现在的您跟当年的您比。
他肯定处于一个比他老的阶段。
所以您现在的写作。
比如说
能不能也换一个角度。
也可能我的作品写的。
是越来越年轻了
并不是越来越
随着时间的话
你写的越来越老
气了
如果是那样的话
大家早不懂了
你说是闲得玩笑年轻的。
还是一地鸡毛
年轻的
仔细读一读
肯定是闲得玩笑更年轻的。
而这个
一个人的话
他活得是越来越年轻。
对于作家是非常非常重要的。
您写的就是
越来越老气
你的作品
都有老人味
谁愿意爱你
不可能啊？
而且的话呢？
你看看有时候
一个做着的
独自的这种年龄层。
读闲得玩笑的
都是二十多岁
三十多岁的人
当然也有四十岁
你看他们的留言
好多生活中出来的。
特别
新鲜的那种年
在
外面与风雨过招
回到家
关门的时候轻轻和上。
老挤
别太辛苦
我觉得这话都很年轻。
是的
而且有这些
所有的
泪水之下漂浮的是所有的人生。
这个的话
这个话
也很深刻
你看他写的
二十多岁
但这个话的话
非常有厚重的
这种质利性
我为什么提到
波夫娃的老年这个事。
其实就是因为
我拿到这个写的玩笑的时候。
确实只看了
您不是结构上还有点。
就是这个证文一
然后题外话33章。
但其实题外话是这个证文。
我就刚看完证文一的时候。
给我一个巨大的感受。
就是刘老师您这个比例。
非常非常强
没有因为
咱们想象中的
年龄的增长
然后体力上会不会有一些不知。
因为我听很多人说过。
写长篇小说是很难的。
他需要很强的体力。
包括一下子全部读完以后。
看到后面也没有卸掉。
所以我会关心
是不是这个事跟您。
比如您爱跑步也有关系。
就是您有这个韧劲。
所以才聊这个老年这个事。
对
其实
当然的话
跟跑步有关系
但是的话
它之间的关联
是这么之间
一个人喜欢一种运动。
是因为这个运动
会给它带来快乐
所以好多人
就说
你很有任性
你很能坚持
就是每天都坚持跑步。
因为这个话
对
但是对我来讲
它肯定是
英国关系是说反了。
因为
首先跑步的话
就是
如果跑步的人都会知道。
跑步马上能给人的话。
就是跑步的过程中。
它会带来
乐器
比如说多巴安
还有一个词的话
内飞菜
它会产生多巴安和内飞菜。
你跑步的过程的话。
就是武藏六府
非常舒服的
这就好像
一个人为什么要写作一样。
你如果说
我就是为了成为一个作者。
我就是要写书
也没有毛病
仅仅是因为的话
写书可能会
给我带来乐器
这是我写书的
最重要的原因
为什么写书的话
会给你带来乐器
为什么输过一个人来乐器。
这是另外一个
这些道理
人为什么喜欢独副。
这里边的话
在闲在玩笑里边
就是
猪太白
跟那个
当中学老师的时候。
跟校长叫曹武车
这人很有意思
曹武车的话
名字就非常有需要。
学书
曹武车就讲了一个道理。
说的特别特别好
杜太白是说的话
因为书不长咒文
这是一个道理
书
永远是年轻的书
才能够留下来
读书的话
要消失自己的咒文。
也对
但看曹武车的话
透彻一些
说世上为什么需要书。
那是因为的话
就是
清朝的生活
跟现在没有太大的区别。
也是一天要吃三顿饭。
结婚生孩子
人类延续下去
一场生活
也是一例计谋
但书最大的好处
不管是史记也好
包括张国策也好
更之前的
像论语也好
道理经也好
它有一个过滤的作用。
这个过滤跟
深世行说的过滤
它又可以
扣上了
因为
清朝和汉朝
唐朝 宋朝
清朝
一滤计谋
过滤是把那些没意思的事。
给过滤掉了
留下来的是
有意思和有意义的事。
把那些没意思
没意义的人给过滤掉了。
留下来的都是有意思的。
有意义的人和事
你当
曹武车说当现实生活。
你赶到的话就是无趣的时候。
有个地方的话
全是有趣的人和事。
你就去读书
你就是跟
实际里边的那些人。
跟唐师宋
辞的那些人
跟红恶梦林那些人。
你相处到一块
他说
我特别喜欢
欲古人居
欲古人谋
我觉得他这个说法。
还是比较大为的
输的
价值
他说
他里边写的一定是有。
意思的事和有
意思和意义的人
那好
我做一个作者来讲。
生活中确实有好多。
有意思和有意义的人和事。
这是有意思和有意义的人。
并不说这个事
它不复材
并不是这个人只有A面。
恰恰是有B面
C面
然后他说
他特别有趣
那你写说的过程也是。
与这些有意思的人和事。
每天相处到一起
是
首先你觉得他有乐趣。
接着的话
你才来写这个书
事实上不少任何一个作者。
我当然也不少任何一个人。
少的是什么呢？
我们意
意识不到
意识到了
是浅意识
但是我没有
把他到
意识的层面的这些有意思的人和事。
那
书里边的话
他有
大家才去看这本书。
这是读书的另外一个乐趣。
读书的乐趣是什么？
他一定的话是要用。
首先有意思
接着还读出了点意义。
这个的话
我觉得是
写书和读书能够产生。
心流的
最基本的原因
就是
书里的人和事都
特别的
我们在生活中都见过。
是见过
但是B面
C面一直到F面
没见过
因为生活在变化
生活层出不穷
所以一个作者
你写作的话
永远没有
说你枯竭的
这种
原权里面碰出了那么多东西。
那你要是事不见
你没感觉到那是另外一回事。
层出不穷的
是这些
新鲜的
有意思的
有意义的人和事
藏的是什么呢？
那些新鲜的思想
新鲜的思想
是非常非常重要
人
是不是成长了
并不是这个人的话。
他变得特别的
扰到
是因为他变得
特别的年轻
这是
你想这个
大家都说的话
不是贺斯
说写得不错
你其实看他的书基本上都是。
故事大杆
但是这些故事大杆里面。
有好多你看一看
他的思想
也是非常新鲜的
其实还有一个作家。
是一个
田俄国和田苏联的。
一个流亡的作家
在德国待过
在美国
他有一个讲稿
文学讲稿
这个讲稿的话
讲过像
欧美的文学
美国的文学
包括俄罗斯的文学。
我读他的书的话
我就能看出来
这个人很年轻
流亡生活中
他思想一直没有停止。
还有两本的话
就是大家约着
特别难读的书
其实与真正产业
现在都
都不难读
尤利西斯吗？
一个就是
普洛斯特的追忆私事年航。
一个就是你刚才说的。
詹姆斯教义
尤利西斯
他写的全是
特别有意思的事和人。
而这些在别的筑读里没有。
当然他俩之间
法国作家和爱尔兰的作家。
他之间有区别
追私事年航
写的是贵族的生活。
一小孩
身体
不是太强壮
早饭吃
在床上
在牛奶
他能吃十几页
他把时间
世上的时间
极大地拉长了
这是个哲学
在日常生活中
这个事发生时间那么短。
但是拉的那么长
尤利西斯的话
写的是一个街头互惠的时候。
不论
普通的
一个广告的推销员。
写的一天的生活
一天的时间
一天的生活的话
他最大的哲学和年轻是在什么地方。
你又想不到
一个这么就是
多布林街头的
一个那么普通的人。
他脑子里的生活
是生色全
我看有个评论
就是说
尤利西斯我就说得挺好的。
是用杂碎写真的试试。
您这一长串
隐身的这么多
我一点点
我缓缓
比如说您刚刚说的。
蜘蛛水年华
他里面不是马德林带小蛋糕吗？
他就写了四五十页。
包括怎么想到他姨妈。
当年给他拿了一个什么断树茶。
这个其实跟您这个。
脚子的展望不是一个事吗？
就是一个事
引起医院一个事
包括您刚刚说这个写作的意义。
或者您为什么写作的时候。
也让我想起您上一回跟这个罗勇浩老师。
你们聊天
他就问您一问题
他说刘老师您现在离开这个故乡也。
挺多年了
为什么还能把这个言经的人物写的这么好。
您是怎么去有意
接触他们还是怎么样。
您当时用了一个词特别好。
您说的是
这个凡事如果像有意去做。
那就做不好了
所以您刚刚说写作的时候。
我也就理解了
您写作本身可能就是要寻找。
那个心流
就是要去见更多
有意思的人
平常在生活中可能知音难密。
但是书里有
写作本身不是为了要写出来一个。
大家读了特别牛逼的作品。
这些人我很有乐趣。
我觉得这个他好
首先
并不是生活中知音难密。
他们就在生活中
有一词的话
说的还是对的
生活中并不
缺乏美
缺乏的是发现
但他这个美
不是说单纸
美学的美
是放出来那种别样的。
是美吗？
其实我看这个书的时候。
其实是在杜泰白跟曹五车。
这一组人物身上
感受到了那种慈悲。
比如说这个曹五车。
就是因为他
杜泰白才从高端跌落的。
从一个老师变成
没职业了
然后第二回
咸猪手事件发生以后。
是因为一篇习文
整个这个事是他又进一步扩大。
那这个习文谁写的呢？
就是曹五车对吧？
但是呢您又安排最后。
在这个城墙上抱头痛哭的。
这个人跟他一块抱头痛哭的人。
又又是曹五车
包括我记得您这几句话。
写的特别好我得给大家念一念。
您当时说的是
你说虽然我跟杜泰白有过节。
但是我们严惊这么大。
至于把杜老师弄成这样吗？
把一个知识分子弄成了一堆垃圾。
包括他还说
你们把杜泰白弄得不说话了。
他沉默了
他是沉默了
但是他沉默的声音正耳欲聋。
懂吗就他有一大段的这样的东西。
然后所以您在这个时候又说。
就说杜泰白就感慨。
就是这几个月以来。
第一次遇到之音
这之音就是曹五车。
曹五车就是跟他吵架的。
把他整个的人生搞得七零八落的这么一个人。
就是这个地方其实也反映了。
就是虽然这个书里没写。
大家总结出来这个话。
就是世界上的每一个人。
都辛苦了
有一种就是江湖上咱们互相抱个拳。
都辛苦了都不容易。
这种慈悲感是我能够。
在这两个人物身上感受到的。
他不是仇敌
另外这个慈悲还有一层含义。
就是人物的复杂性。
对对对
过去的敌人他成了。
最知心的朋友
说出了别人都说不出来的话。
这个规律的话
就是世界上没有什么人物关系。
是不可以改变的
包括的话
就是
我看好多朋友看了的话。
就是说看到那个地方。
还是山人类下
就是
他的前妻
两人的话
你一直是
他不对付
是这个
俩人就是平常在特别小的事。
嗯
然后的话呢就是但是呢？
他俩是敌对细事
枪着说
但这个在生活中太多了。
是的
我同事就说他说他爸妈说话。
就是这么说的
不但他爸妈
医院你的爸妈的话。
关系很好
但是呢好多人都是这么敌对细事。
说这个有吓死人了。
多穿这衣服
用你说
这事你看吧一片好衣。
是吧？
这样一瓶在那放着。
你眼瞎呀？
柜子上不看看
他这样
说俩人就离婚
没想到话当
这个粗吃的话呢？
当那个
杜太白
堂城上
然后就坐着也不动。
就是一坐一天
到晚上生了一小孩子。
还在那坐着
他的前踢就能路过。
天冷该回去了
嗯
我不认识你
打你
这是过去的敌对细事。
马上醒过来了
你说打你知道是谁了。
是吧？
他们都离婚了不一家。
回家
他又成过去的状态。
他就跟他跳跳回去了。
大门口的话
又说的话这是我家。
不是你家你回去的。
杜太白
成了这个样子
回家你看你髒的
都是我去洗个澡吧？
我不会洗澡
他一下给
把他推进去
又把他给弄到这个卫生间。
让他把衣服全脱了。
用那喷头给他洗头。
接着的话又给他洗身子。
接着又给他弄到卧室。
然后的话
把他盖上被子走
嗯
那这个的话呢就是。
两个敌对细事的人。
最后的话
又出现这样的场景。
这个在生活中也很常见。
嗯
文学和书里的话
这个人物结构的话。
特别有力量
这个有力量的话
就把他前提的
B面 C面给
写出来了
没有任何一个人说。
他就是个纯粹的坏人。
还有一个他也没有纯粹的好人。
这我必须得给你念。
要不然没机会了
您说的这段就是我们一个读者。
他在我们群里发的。
我就是有机会
是吧？
我赶紧先给您念了。
他是说
你看他就是说
一个叫十二间
就是信间的那个间。
他说他说
让我感觉到一种无可奈何。
渴望被理解被爱的人。
生活中面临着无处可躲的孤独和误解。
误解和孤独
但同时
所有那么一些人有那么一些时刻。
点亮了一切
很喜欢闲的玩笑里面。
前期把肚菜排拖回去洗澡的那一段。
把质倾质书
就是倾书
质倾质书的父亲关系。
协和了
他就是特喜欢这段。
然后因为我们在分享。
你看他这个质倾质书这词用的也很好。
是
你看
这个朋友的话
他就是能从这一则。
这学的质倾和质书。
他之间的这个
辩证的关系
他在一起的时候
他并不那么亲
输了之后
前去都嫁了另外一个人了。
他突然的话又
对前夫是这个样子。
这个有时候是
人间的
质倾说质
但这个质倾的话已经超越了。
就是我们社会规范的。
这样的就是比如讲。
人和人之间的关系。
你而离婚了
相互都没关系了
还有离婚了
越惨越好
但其实都不是这样的。
都说人心是肉长的。
其实不是
是肉长的
但是他有时候是
人性和灵活
有时候人性和灵活。
是非常复杂
和多面的
就是多面
然后是
威胁
特别想到达的一个景地。
这有时候是跟
三文和随笔的
一个非常大的区别。
对
包括您书里面还塑造了一个人。
这个我们当时也在我们的那个读者群里面。
讨论了
杜天威这个人
杜太白他爸
有一些读者他就说。
他觉得他爸就是这样的。
在外面天天
八戒别人
讨好别人 非常窝呢？
回到家里面窝里哼。
对老婆孩子都是动辄打骂。
这样的形象太常见了。
但是你知道让我最动容的。
其实是
后来这不是小时候一个黑猪。
回来了吗？
他就问杜太白一个问题。
当年有一人
喝醉了 还跑猪圈里。
还哭呢？
你看你把他这一哭。
就写出来了
就是我们所理解的那个。
包括咱们这个中国社会里面。
很常见的一种复提形象。
他也有另一面
那一面我只能去猜测。
那一面可能就是
他知道他自己是个啥人。
他知道他自己在外面不是个人。
在家里面
就是家人也讨厌他。
所以他没有能力改变形象。
他就只能偶尔喝多了。
然后往猪圈里面一哭。
然后这也就是说
中国很常见的这种复提形象。
他的把护的背面
就是他的无能
就是这个人物
特好塑造的特封
对
因为
杜天威这个人的话。
在生活中也是非常常见的。
他不常见的话
他还有
另外一面
这也是杜天威的另外一种。
异彩
我觉得比这更重要的。
异彩的话是他死的时候。
然后的话
就是他
八年初一
不行了
这个时候他
确实的话
他没有能力的话
在家里才十五一分。
你别几点死
你大年初一点死的话。
凡是过年的时候
都特别会气
明天再死
不耍威风了
因为能力耍威风了。
但是
他点点头
坚持
到大年初二死了
这是这个人的随命。
这个杜太白就说
一个人
一个人别的事能忍。
人死
是
非常的话
极大的毅力
他终于发现
他确实是个人物
为什么是个人物呢？
因为他说人死带军。
因为杜太白是个真人分子嘛？
结果在葫芦里写了。
是
说人死带军
这是个点呼
是为民地
然后人死的时候
就是不死
因为这个时候
统筛的军队的人是叫司曼依。
他在外地呢？
就是
一天
五朝
就是说让他赶紧回来。
这个司曼依
看到那上面有三个字。
赶紧回来
十五面
然后他突然说
昨天晚上
我都做了一梦
梦见皇上
十五面
他躺在我这个
腿上
我看到面色好像不太好。
就知道国家出大事了。
皇上的
这是闹着玩的
就是
五百里
也要赶回去了
然后赶紧进到那个殿里边。
这个是为民地
说
人死带军
是因为的话
交给他要的一个
儿子其实的侄子叫曹芳。
是吧？
希望你能拥带新军。
司曼依这个时候
痛苦流涕
赶补一死军中
接着他点点头
就崩了
就糟了
那就
在这个时候
跟为民军是一样的。
他终于知道他父亲。
也是个人物
这个
当然是
一个人物他随着故事的眼睛。
他不断的发生变化。
但这个变化的话
它是
符合生活规律的
就是一人你看他年轻时候。
那样他多晚年成这样的。
一个人年轻时候
那样他现在又成
那那样了
这日常生活中也是这样。
朋友里
多是偷偷不觉的一人。
突然都不说话了
你不知道他心里有什么心事。
这个有时候是
文学需要
关注的那些方面
关注的方面有时候可能在生活中。
是被忽略的方面
包括您说
这个心在哪
这个书里面当然还有一面。
就是您有处理一个非常当下的东西。
可以讲它是一种互联网困境。
就是其实
我一直在想杜太白。
他遭遇的这个困境。
还真挺难用一两句话说明白的。
是吧？
但是呢？
对 复杂
因为黑猪说你给我简短说。
他说简短不了的吧？
我这个长话很
他就说那如果一定要简短的话。
就是四个字
叫动辄得救
然后你能不能给我们解释解释。
这个词包括或者咱也可以聊聊。
就是杜太白他在互联网里面。
遇到的这个困境他到底是什么？
一个的话呢就是
动辄得救的话呢？
因为他是个成语
因为杜太白遇到困境之后。
他无法说清楚
因为这个时候他又有互联网。
大家这个相信的呢？
是情绪并不是真相。
当那个真相的话呢？
还在穿鞋的时候
这个谎言
然后趁着这个互联网的话。
已经
跑遍了全世界
无一自白
越说呢？
这个事是越苗越黑。
这是杜太白的
杜太白的最大的困境。
最大的困境并不是。
你遇到了什么事
你想玩这个事说成他不是这个事。
把一事做好的不容易。
把一事说成
不是这个事是更不容易。
你证明你
那不是杜太白他爸一辈子。
都想证明他自己吗？
不容易
但是你把自己说成不是你。
我不是这个我
有了会
更不容易
而且就是
这个
往困境的人
身上扔石头
不相似的人身上扔石头。
大姐都是慷慨的
然后就是
杜太白的话呢？
跟这个身世行有一段对话。
就是说
平常这个人给我扔石头人。
都很善良
通往地狱的道路
不就的
我觉得这里边的话。
就是
塑造了另外一个人物形象。
我觉得
也是这个人的
B面 C面
F面
XY和Z面的一个人。
就是小林
小林是定鞋的
而且的话
过去的话
杜太白
两人关系还挺好
杜老师
你眼睛最有学能力。
你能把我这个
这个电名给改一改。
说为什么呀？
因为我把他叫小林那个。
小鞋铺
东街还有一家小林的小鞋铺。
我的生意比他好
他就老来绕
说我抄袭他的电名了。
我不不想跟他闹
杜太白有学能力
要不叫我时光旅恨。
是吧？
就穿鞋嘛？
时光旅恨
明儿还没叫起来
关心那么好
就是突然的话
有一天杜太白遇到困境的时候。
他写了一个西文
文文啊？
而且杜太白一看
有点
像两个人写的
一个是陶曹曹西
这个小林
一定写的
他怎么这么有学问。
他要有学问
他让我写名呢？
他就找的
就是小林是你写的。
他说你为什么？
要写这么一个文章。
博士
这样的新闻很难语。
我写这个
我涨了不少粉呢？
不知道
就是这个小林
白天定邪
晚上原来是
一个线重装网上的大威。
白天的话
是定邪
晚上骂人
骂人是
为什么呢？
因为能待粉
而且他骂上去人都不认识。
全是
这些各地的那种
名人
骂他们没有任何代价。
而且你只要骂他们。
好像跟他们是平等的。
甚至居高零下在骂他们。
好像就比他们高
其实这个定邪的
那你就纯粹为了骂人们。
不是
为了带这个带货
什么货呀？
脚气水
还有防臭鞋店
脚气水和防臭鞋店。
你都这么干了
小林
现在
线上
不得不发
这次你都知道
这个人物关系
特别有意思
当然你写的时候
就是有这个人物塑造。
其实我看的时候
有很多
其实很触目惊心的感觉。
不止有小林
还有他的亲家
村里的其他人
他其实
您在那个嘻笑怒骂之间。
其实也写出了互联网的。
试写的一面
破窗效应
这个地方出了点事。
所有人大家都一红而上。
为什么呢 为流量。
包括最近有一个新闻。
一个人的口碑
他是可以从很差
为什么？
然后我就看有一个人写了一个分析的文章。
他说这里边有个节点。
当自媒体们
发现捧一个人
比骂这个人流量还高的时候。
他就会选择捧这个人。
所以我说您这个书里面。
其实写的非常深刻。
就是您把这个试写的一面写了出来。
对
他最后总有个目的。
就是
万千的这种
纷繁的这种现象
是文学关注的
但文学关注的是
他为什么会这么形成。
达到的目的是什么？
你看着的话
有好多事的话
很奇怪
他其实不奇怪
有时候的话是出于。
例
比如两下相联要待会。
有时候是一种情绪。
情绪的发泄
没有出口
突然有一个公众的出口。
就是
闸门开了
所有刷水就过去了。
你才说过
世上并无真相
只有角度
哎呀？
其实我都跟你寻藏了。
你知道吗？
一千多年前
你能不能的话呢？
告诉我一个真相
第二 你看吧？
要不你呢？
因为这个真相有个历史。
又联系在一起了
因为真相跟真理
有时候都存在于历史中。
就看
真理掌握在谁手里。
掌握在谁手里
这个真相就是真相。
说一个事的话
是这样的
那好
这恰恰是文学要关心的。
既有这样 也有那样。
也有那样
就是包括刚才你说的那个黑猪。
嗯
就是杜太白
她妈一样的
那猪还是长得还有个模样的。
门心上还有一个红巨。
是吧？
因为杜太白的父亲。
和周天妹的话呢？
外边讨好人
这过年嘛？
要杀猪嘛？
因为没杀呢？
你想把猪的所有的肉。
都许个有头有脸的人呢？
是的 根本不够分。
还不够
回来的话要发愁嘛？
就拿这个尺子的话。
就凉着猪的体积面积。
猪是真极了
说你杀我没关系
在你没杀呢？
你把我许着
连我都不够
杀上了天的话呢？
突然跑
但以为杀猪猪跑很正常。
谁都不愿意死
说把她给抓回来吧？
没想到她
不是跑 说跑到村头的话呢？
一个机警的帮助她跳进去了。
这话说的话呢？
就是
这有
60年过去
杜太白在太山
突然碰到这村
陪看杜太白你在干嘛呢？
杜太白这时候真到绝境了。
是要请山上跳下去。
但
不跟猪说这个话嘛？
他就说为了看日出。
别装了
因为什么我自杀过。
我知道这个自杀的眼神。
但以此之前的话呢？
还有啥问题
找你主要是这事
说什么问题
第一个问题的话
就是说
当时你们家的猪见给杨健是挨着的嘛？
强了扒了一个鞭子。
有一小孩
89岁
每天用那鞭子抽
人是你嘛？
他说为什么抽
我50年了我都没想清楚。
我死不明目
就这一条
都在想着想
没什么原因
就是没事了
手欠就抽着玩
这还有天理嘛？
第二次
第二次就是刚刚我们讨论的事。
你爸
我傻的
他站我也不知道
还有一个就说什么？
当时你们杀过的时候。
这个脚上记得是活坑。
为什么记活坑
谁记得
如果是死坑我肯定跑不了。
说我没见跟铁
我也不知道
是啥问题
这解决了一个
第一个问题
包括说咱们
是怎么聊到这儿的。
其实还是因为我刚跟您聊。
就是他所遭遇的那个。
网报也好或者那个互联网困境也好。
其实您聊到猪的时候。
聊得非常非常对您记忆力好好。
就是这条线一直没有断。
看到那个猪问他
小时候
总有一小孩抽我
为什么抽我
他说也没啥原因
就是手欠
我看到那儿的时候就明白了。
就是我们可能每一个人。
他都有可能是那个。
在网上
出于手欠也好
或者根本没有意识也好。
也不知道对那个人会造成多大伤害。
去发出那个
再来一个咸的玩笑。
导致他有这个咸的遭遇。
对
就是看到那儿的时候我真的就。
就您说的这个小故事。
留到那儿的时候
特别的浑然天成跟前面全都串上了。
就因为我在网上也在关注。
各种留言
我发现很多人他们。
感兴趣的一个点就是。
关于寒冬跟装死
而我看有一些功耗也把这个装死。
两个字给拎出来
这个概念怎么理解。
我们如果真的在一个。
特别大的困境里面。
装死管用吗？
这个装死的问题也没解决。
首先装死这个概念。
不是坐着提出来的。
坐着提出来的概念。
在书中都是浅浅的。
春涯提出来的
这个春涯的话
它符合它的身份
而且符合它的见识。
春涯的话是一个
不高的人就是个中端生。
他是肚腾白的
前若夕
但是肚腾白的话
每次跟他见面
跟他聊天都发现
虽然文化不高
但是见识可是不及。
我这看上去特别长远。
这个人有时候在生活中。
也是经常常见的
并不一定的话
这个人他有学历
就证明他有认知
有好多的话他没上过多学。
但是他看事的话
就是看得特别的远。
特别的透气
这种人我是非常非常尊重的。
我们出了好多人的话。
他也没上过什么学。
但是有时候你听他谈。
他真是能谈出来另外一番的话。
道理包括另外一番天地。
卖子
市场面什么最好吃。
就是白面
卖子可不是2G 3G。
那种跟道子似的
他要经历过一年的四季。
春天播种
经过冬天
再经过春天
再经过夏天收割
他卖子的话
一到冬天的话
卖苗的话全枯黄了。
但是春天他突然发了一个。
心眼又长起来了
这个时候卖子在干嘛？
在装死
卖子在装死
第二年春天的话
心眼又发了
说春天总是会来到的。
给时间一点时间
然后就渡台湾
就听了春天的话
然后渡过了这个困境。
它是一个生活的哲学。
这个生活的哲学并不深奥。
但是的话
他有时候针对生活来讲。
他还是个治理
卖子
它不是真死
它是装死
等待着是来年春天。
对吧？
然后我们就在我们那个。
读者群里面也讨论了这个问题。
然后有一个人
我名字可能没记清。
他叫叶莫彬
他就在详细的在想拆解一下。
装死是什么？
他就提了一个词是低头。
他说这个装死
有一个妥协的艺术。
有一个低头的艺术。
我就不知道您在讲。
装死这个概念的时候。
有没有这样一层所谓的一个。
低头的艺术
我觉得低头这个词不准确。
因为低头你承认对方是对的。
我觉得是沉默
沉默
所以就是
曹武车在程先生就说。
他不说话了
他的沉默正耳欲聋。
我觉得
无疑自明的时候
他就不说话
那谁会说话呢？
实验
关于这个装死
其实我还想到一个。
就是我之前采访的一个人。
是秦丽巡老师
他就有一个概念
他说的是
当你看不清一个事情的时候。
或者你不知道该怎么办的时候。
就是
观察
等待
做事
我觉得他跟你那个装死。
好像也有点像
就是面对困境的一个办法。
观察
等待
做事
就是这个
秦丽巡老师也是一个。
非常有学问的人
我觉得他
而且
他有自己
独特的见解
包括他对
这个
弄性的研究
我觉得非常的深入。
那当然像田老师里边说这个概念。
其实的话
就是跟那个
独裁
他妈说的概念的话。
是相同的
就是等待
跟和尚说的也是一样的。
嗯
为什么要等待呢？
因为世界上
唯一相信的是
时间
时间相信的是变化。
没有不变化的事
所以致命和尚
就说反正说一个事一成不变的。
要么是物质
要么是骗子
就是有见识的人
就是
非常道
这是有道理的
有时候一本书的话。
他的成立有时候也在非常道。
这个非常道
是一个非常好的概念。
是我们河南人提出来的。
嗯
行理
理了
包括我还在回想
您刚刚说的那个沉默。
其实这个也是
我也是看到网上有一个文学批评家徐道正。
他在写您这篇文章的。
一个评论的时候
他也提到了
他就说在一个
网络迅速发展信息。
高速传递传播的一个过程中。
有一个旧的轮理
好像已经被摧毁了。
但是一个新的轮理还没有建立起来。
然后他就用了您刚刚那个词。
就是无以自明自无以明。
然后这个时候
您写的这个主题是非常非常。
就是深刻的
就是说这可能是您下本书。
继续的主题
就是当一个旧轮理。
就是摧毁新轮理没建立的时候。
然后当您说这个沉默的时候。
我也在想
这个沉默里边是不是也有做事。
因为你不是光沉默。
你也是要慢慢的
做正确的事情
嗯
前先生肯定的话
是说这个
一方面等待一方面做事。
对
按自己的方向和见识来做自己的事。
嗯
这个方面当然是对的。
还有沉默本身就是做事。
嗯
另外的话呢？
就是为什么要沉默。
就像冰淇淇说的
就是
旧的
这种轮理的基础
包括见识的基础
没了
那谁建立呢？
嗯
就是等待和做事的人在建立嘛？
你做事的话呢？
当然你写的玩笑他也是做事嘛？
对
所以写的玩笑
这个我看那个
有些网上的留言总结的比我好。
嗯
说世上的每一个人。
都有厌倒
肚子里的玩笑和眼泪。
嗯
然后这个眼泪不得咸的嘛？
就把这玩笑给咸的。
他说的最好的比我想的好。
就是咽到肚子里的。
嗯
咽到肚子里的话就是。
无以自明
无以言表
不足以外人道
嗯
所以的话他不就是咽到肚子里的嘛？
就是咽到肚子里的眼泪和玩笑。
有时候
恰恰是
更大的
咸的玩笑
我就是大家敢知道了。
我觉得这对读者来讲是一个。
极大的
鞭策
包括鼓励
然后
我争取把下一部书能够写的更好一些。
期待
包括您刚说到对太白的时候。
我又想起来您以前。
一句地方一句里面也写过一句话。
您说小事
是可以指望别人的。
大事千万不能指望别人。
得靠自己
我觉得杜太白在您的这个书写里面。
您虽然那一张是直接跳到了结尾。
那肯定还是靠着他自己。
走出来的
而他靠着自己的话。
是他
听着所有的事中
他自己一点一点的干苦。
有点干苦自知嘛？
靠自己自己一点的。
悟出来的
这个跟
开篇
然后写在知名和尚。
我觉得突然
在这个地方里面
契合了
当然这个知名和尚的话。
就是他跟
杜太白
没有任何交集
其实真正的交集不是见面。
真正的交集是一个。
认识
好多人没见过面
他可能是你特别好的亲人。
知名和尚的话
因为
他挺小的话
确实
尝尽了生活的这种。
干苦
然后是
父亲是一个秘像
整天边狂边柔
这母亲的话
是爱打麻将
他生在了麻将
抓下7个月
4岁才会走路
他妈对着带他改嫁了。
另一个村的话
祭父是一个
铁匠
后院的话
就有个祖父
结满了祖父
秋天的话祖父了
小孩嘛？
想吃个早
突然背后有人说的话。
他走路都是有树的。
他走过这么一生
是祖父
然后
第二天的话就是刮风了。
走落了一地
祖父说你要想吃早。
去地上捡几个
他爸我不爱吃早
然后他母亲的话
在院子里晒一早
想晒成早干
打牌子少爱吃的零子。
抓给他一把吃吧？
他母亲就找他一下。
把他扔到院外去
清明节
他就跟他妈说
他特别想回原来的村子。
给他亲爸的
上个坟
他妈说你要想去就去吧？
祖父看了
他妈一想就去吧？
上坟的话
他没有回来
他去了泰安
他说了两个舅舅
也是一个结构
一个知名和尚的舅舅。
一个是独太白的舅舅。
舅舅家的话
清明节目
他舅妈
家里小孩都围着那个锅台。
吃锅的蛮醉油
舅妈就以为
他是来赶嘴吃的
没理
知名的俗人叫常树。
没理常树
是自己家的孩子
让祖先吃的
你们都先吃生意
常树你吃饭了吗？
没吃
吃过
他就是泰山一挑夫。
然后说
我上山给葡萄寺送东西。
你跟我去
出了门
他就意味
眼睛是红的
因为又受了祭父的气。
不是受了
这次不是受了祭父的气。
是在亲爸坟上
哭红的
因为在眼底里
一孩子在那儿哭
没有人劝了
我刚好在读着说
看到这个地方
他还是特别难过
掉下了眼泪
生有两个上了葡萄寺。
然后的话
就是
很多个和尚
都在那儿念阴
常常看到这个场面。
出来跟他舅舅说
我知道该干啥了
该干啥
当和尚
当和尚清闲是吧？
念给镜头不是的
这么多人都没爸没妈。
也不是没爸没妈
是离开爹妈大姐都一样。
就是说
嗨
当和尚
就不受后爸的气了。
接着把他带到主持那屋。
主持人问他
你为什么想当和尚。
当了和尚就医疗白疗。
主持人就
哎呀你看
这孩子有点肤圆
在舅舅旁边说
请小舅外稍相拜扶。
那你就别天佑加粗了。
但葡萄寺在太山
说来的人多没空
你急不急
他说急
要急
妙小嫌不嫌
不嫌
雾缘嫌不嫌
离家越缘越好
这话又想要扶缘
接着呢是
严定有个机名寺
机名寺这个方丈
早年呢在葡萄寺挂个单。
跟着主持相熟
主持呢就给他写了一封信。
带着这封信不愿千里来到我们眼睛。
然后就成了志明
这话说
六十多年过去
然后
志明的话呢就把这个寺人弄到天火。
特别的心动
他舅舅过来就
八十多了来看他
对
然后他见着舅舅
他说老寺住远道而来。
辛苦了
这寺里的规矩
反竟两届分的是很清楚的。
他就有马上说
有劳和尚
接着陪着舅舅吃了一顿饭。
第二天他舅舅要走。
送到机名山下
这个时候
志明和尚的话
就把自己的那一给拖下来了。
就成了寿人了
突然跪到地上说
舅舅再上寿
长寿一拜
就是自小命苦
反竟两届有两进两出。
每次都得到舅舅的价值。
对我您就是活不帅。
他赶紧给他缠进来了。
长寿儿自华严重了。
舅舅就是个挑拂
向心疼外生
但有心无力
才是你到了这不天地。
但是看在机名寺
相互形容
忠诚正国
舅舅也就放心了
说还有个事
你清醒了的话
受了不少委屈
是因为
你妈呢 脾气狼的。
你后爸呢 心也有点狭窄。
你原谅他们吧？
何况他们已经死了。
他们都是我的恩人。
没有他们
我就不会有今天
没有今天我就无处悟道。
不悟道我就成了他们一样的人。
他就想不想
这话有些刻薄呀？
但脸是这么跟脸
把你舅妈也算到那边吧？
当年没给你那个纸。
对对对
我从小吃百家来长大的。
人情冷暖
众生共业
正是慈悲的来源
舅舅走了
一直的话
到舅舅山洞
转个角都看不见了。
致命河上还在那儿。
站着
致命河上也是
经过好多这种
比如讲像
坎坷也好
就是
不是也好
但是它中程正过
这个结构的话呢？
致命河上跟
独太板
并无交地
但是的话呢？
就是在许多认识上。
突然达成了一致
这个我就是结构
最讲究的
还有一个的话
从地方上来讲
一个是从太安来到了。
严禁
一个是从严禁又到了。
太安
这个也是
一个人物的结构
在写这个时候
有时候你是也能误道的。
能误道道
是一个特别的
一个重要的
像
致命河上说的
是一个来源
而这个来源的话呢？
就是
它可能让一个作者。
可能下一步多数学得更。
年轻一些
您刚说的致命河上的这个故事。
我看的时候就很感动。
您刚又讲了一遍的时候。
我就觉得刘老师
以前昆大
有连草木青
就给我的这个感觉。
期待刘老师的下一步作品。
谢谢冰仙
没想到你聊了四个多小时。
谢谢刘老师
下一本书的时候
再聊一次
希望不要让我们等四年。
但是有时候
写作思考需要时间。
给时间一点时间
那我们就在那边等。
笨的话
需要更多的时间
笨的人才能长久
这是您上回采访的时候说的。
好吧？
谢谢大家
谢谢
谢谢大家都辛苦了。
在做的每一个人都辛苦了。